[Music]
hello everyone today we will be looking
at the interview questions which are
typical DevOps engineer faces in an
interview this is both for people who
are new to the DevOps world and people
who are experienced in other fields like
Linux or production support and are
willing or wanting to move to DevOps so
let's take a look so pretty much it'll
start with questions about yourself
they'll have a resume in front of them
as obviously you would have sent your
resume to them so they'll look at that
and they will ask you to quickly walk
them through your resume and tell them
what you've been doing in your previous
project so you'll have to summarize this
in a way in which you know kind of walk
through all three layers and you have to
tell them that you work on a team where
you kind of managed aw the AWS part and
the automation part of it so that can
also include telling them about any
infrastructure deployment scripts which
you have written it could also include
any configuration management that you've
done and deployment automation you might
have done so it would also include
things like setting up a monitoring
system setting up the entire thing on
the cloud collaborating with teams
everything maybe what your code review
process is scrum methodology whatever
you do in your team they will definitely
ask you what your team size was so you
could say you've been working on a team
about five to six people which would
include team leads consultants managers
scrum masters etc what was your role in
the team that's the typical DevOps role
in which you've written code for
automation of stuff on the cloud they'll
ask how good are you at programming now
this is a typical question that's asked
of a DevOps engineer to gauge whether
he's fit for the DevOps role or not so
you would answer that you've not written
full-fledged applications such as Java
or Ruby on Rails but you're good at Ruby
Python shell and Perl from a scripting
language perspective maybe I'm not a
full-fledged programmer but I know the
ins and outs of scripts one of the
typical questions is are you from the
dev side or the ops side and the answer
is you're from the ops side but you
a good hold on the programming languages
which are used for scripting and
configuration management and whatever
code is required you can write that
easily they may ask how quickly can you
learn which is a gauge of the candidates
ability to learn new things and
flexibility to adjust himself to a new
environment given the chance can you
architect an application the answer is
definitely yes
tell them you have been working with
architects recently and that you've been
contributing to the architecture from a
DevOps perspective and giving your input
so that the application could be
developed in a more easily deployable
manner given the chance to lead a team
can you do that you'll say yes
definitely I have more than five years
experience typically this is true for
people who have at least five years
experience leaving a team because less
than that would really not be meaningful
the next level of questions that come up
in a DevOps interview are typically
Linux questions these questions could be
anything from the Linux world but
typically these are the most common
questions what is the command to view
the crontab the command is crontab - L
what is an alias in Linux an alias and
Linux is something that tells you the
shortcuts on that system these are
defined in the et Cie batch RC file what
does the chmod command do the chmod
command basically allows you to change
the permission of a file in Linux it can
be changed from read write and
executable mode so it could be changed
from read to read write or to read write
execute depending on the use case what
is SSH port forwarding it's a way to
actually forward your ports through SSH
protocols so it allows you to bypass
firewalls and also tunnel ports through
strictly guarded environments so this is
one of the ways which you can connect to
instances or services in your private
subnets in AWS or your data center the
next question is what is a zombie
process now this is about the most
common Linux question asked in an
interview zombie process is a process
which is in a terminated state but which
has not yet released the resources so
basically it's most commonly a child
process where the parent has exited but
the child is still there basically its
entry is in the process table they'll
ask how
check the top CPU consuming processes
and you can use the top command to check
that the top command gives you a very
nice view of the entire Linux process
table looking at the top deployment
related questions which is one of the
most important areas people use to gauge
their candidates one of the questions
which comes up is what is a Bluegreen
deployment so a Bluegreen deployment is
something that in which you have X
number of resources running your
application and say that number is 10 so
you have 10 servers in a web form now in
a Bluegreen deployment what you do is
take out half of those from the actual
production state you deploy the new code
on those now in the meantime the other
five or the other half would be serving
the production traffic and these 5 would
not be hindered or hampered in any way
now the first 5 in which you complete
the deployment which you've taken out of
the actual production load you put those
back in and you wait for those to come
back into service and then you take the
other 5 out of the actual load and you
start deploying on those so in a
Bluegreen deployment what happens is you
never let the end user see the downtime
it's an always up environment how do you
do a hot deployment this is just a
rephrasing of the previous question
really a hot deployment can be done
either by having two environments of the
same size and then you redirect traffic
through a load balancer or a proxy
service to one of the environments
deploy it on the other and then redirect
to the first one and apply it to the
second and just like a Bluegreen
deployment you never show the end user
the downtime and what is your roll back
strategy this is something you need to
be very confident about because every
deployment should have a roll back
associated with it so let's say your
deployment fails how do you roll back
the system it has to be linked to a blue
green or a hot deployment so you have to
say that you have a Jenkins job or a
script which basically does a blue green
deployment and in the middle of that
blue green deployment it checks to see
whether or not services are up and
running and at the least the sgtp
endpoints of your application are
running or not
have you used Jenkins for deployment yes
I've used it and you've used it using a
couple of strategies you've used it with
plugins and
I've used it with my script so my
plugins used to deploy code on the
environment using build or publish or
SSH and I have also had my ansible or
chef or puppet code which used to do the
deployment for me so we used to use
Jenkins as an Orchestrator and puppet
and chef and ansible for the actual
deployment of the target service one of
the other common questions from a
deployment perspective is what Jenkins
plugins have you used you would say
Jenkins plugins you've used maven and
Gradle I've used kebechet for testing
PMD for programmatic mistake detection
Aztek for Ruby on Rails testing karma
for angularjs testing and integration
with s3 I've also used git plug-in for
checking out code SVN plug-in for
checking out SVN repositories upstream
downstream plugin for connecting the
builds in addition to this have also
used archive artifacts plug-in publish
HTML reports plug-in to publish test
reports have you ever used user data for
deployment you answer yes I've used it
in AWS so when you have instances behind
load balances we used to use it it will
actually defy the deployment script so
that every time a new instance comes up
in the auto scaling group it has got the
latest code on it so that latest code is
checked out using the SH command which
is specified inside the user data
looking at the AWS questions so what is
a V PC a V PC is a slice of the Amazon
Cloud which they give you to run your
resources what is the difference between
a public and private subnet a public
subnet is a subnet which is directly
accessible from the internet a private
subnet is a subnet that is not
accessible from the internet it's only
accessible from within the V PC what is
reserved instance a reserved instance is
an instance which is reserved for you by
Amazon for a year and they give you
significant price reductions on that you
can buy that no upfront partial upfront
or full upfront payments and you get
discounts from 20 to 60 percent based on
the payment type and Terms what is the
difference between spot instance and
reserved instance the spot instance is
like a bid instance where you have a
specific price which you have
and based on that you were assigned
instances now the moment your bid is
lower than the next highest bid your
instance is terminated and it's assigned
to the next highest bidder a reserved
instance on the other hand is not a bit
Abul instance you have to buy it for a
specific terms what is cloud formation
cloud formation is an orchestration or
an infrastructure or a server deployment
tool a managed turbines deployment tool
or service which Amazon provides so it
takes the G Sun as an input in that G
Sun you provide everything that is
required to build up an environment from
VPS to servers to buckets everything so
it's an Amazon provided service that
lets you build entire application stacks
from scratch
have you used route 53 yes I've used
route 53 I used it for managing DNS I
use it to redirect our code ID DNS to
route 53 using Amazon name servers and
then from there in route 53 we used to
create CNM entries a records MX records
txt records and we used to manage the
entire DNS from there what is the best
feature of AWS which you like I like the
auto scaling group and the elastic load
balancer because it allows you to
infinitely scale your application to any
level coming to configuration management
which configuration management tool have
you used so you can say that you've used
all three chef ansible and puppet in one
project or another I have good hands-on
experience with each of them and I've
written chef cookbooks puppet modules
and ansible play books what is the
difference between chef and ansible so
chef is a ruby based tool you users Ruby
as its main programming language it's
open source just like ansible chef uses
a client server and client only
architecture so the difference is that
ansible is simply an agentless tool so
there is no agent in ansible whatsoever
in chef there are two methodologies one
is agent based and the other is agent
list but if you talk about the
difference one of the differences is
that there is no agent in ansible and
the other difference is ansible uses
yamo for defining the state of
the systems in its playbooks whereas
chef uses Ruby for defining the state of
the systems in its cookbooks and it's
more of a programming language when it
comes to chef and amel in ansible is not
really a programming language it's more
of a statically typed code
have you written any cookbooks or
modules and the playbooks
yes I've used both from the repositories
which each of these configuration
management tools provide so for chef's
I've used the chef's supermarket
cookbooks and I've also written custom
cookbooks for puppet I have used modules
from puppet Forge and I've written my
own modules for custom applications for
ansible I've used the community provided
Play Books as well as I've written my
own custom play books for provisioning
of instances on the cloud as well as
managing and now production support what
is the biggest issue you've faced in a
production environment so you can say
that there's an application we used to
run on the cloud and there was some
application deployment error it was a
logical error in the application which
caused an error behind the elastic load
balancer so we had an elastic load
balancer which was tied to the auto
scaling group so it kind of snowballed
the application and we were not able to
control it so the application scaled
infinitely and it was snowballing the
instances so we had to go in and
manually freeze the size of the auto
scaling group once the size was frozen
we were able to go into the instances
check the logs fix the issue rebuild the
ami and restart the auto scaling process
so that was one of the biggest issues in
production I faced recently what is your
D our strategy and a live website so a D
our strategy is that you do a failover
check using route 53 DNS so one of them
is a DNS based failover in which you've
got an exact replica of your environment
your web servers your database your
cache so your database may not be sync
in real time with a dr so it could be a
one day behind sync so the traffic is
switched to dr whenever there's a
downtime in production automatically
through a DNS switch the other dr
strategy is that you can have instances
in to availability zones and then you
can have your load balancer to switch
traffic based on the available
those two zones but that is a same
region DNR so from a multi region DNR
the best option is to have a DNS base to
switch and you can also have an
interface tool interface proxy which can
route traffic based on the health of
your endpoints how do you scale a
production web service so if you're on
the cloud you can use the auto scaling
group which will scale automatically
based on demand if you don't want to go
into instances and you don't want to
manage instances you can use the elastic
beanstalk for a managed stack which
takes care of the load balancing itself
if you have an application which is
already containerized it's a better
practice to run them on EECS on the
cloud which would allow you to scale
your applications based on demand and
you can create an application load
balancer there if you're in house you
can scale your application by having a
container management system in which you
can have some base hosts on which you
run multiple services so you can keep on
adding multiple hosts to that cluster
and you don't have to worry about the
scaling part because the hosts can be
added on the fly to that hardware so
your docker cluster like a swarm or a
kubernetes can take care of getting
those new machines into your cluster and
running the containers which are
existing on your cluster on those new
machines thanks a lot everyone this is
all from the interview question
Hey want to become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
Channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here